estamos apoyando convoyes por
primeramente por la libertad de
expresión la libertad a decidir el
primero para terminar los mandatos
marginales los mandatos de máscaras para
que todas las personas tengan derecho a
poder escoger qué es lo que van a hacer
con su cuerpo las personas no están
pidiendo que no sea contra las vacunas
la mayoría de los camioneros al 90%
vacunados están pidiendo simplemente que
terminen los mandatos y termine en el
estado de emergencia en canadá porque
está afectando a muchas personas en el
labio en el ámbito mental emocional
familiar y también laboral
yo david ramírez soy un empresario
también ha afectado las los negocios los
comercios canadienses la economía la
inflación
queremos simplemente que ya pasemos a un
a una segunda etapa lo que llama la post
pandemia es podamos liberar todo lo que
es las restricciones que se han hecho
durante esos dos años donde los
canadienses han tenido mucha presión
muchos blogs downs muchos cierres de
negocios y queremos simplemente que el
gobierno diga ya basta